so my name is Dan Ariely and I'm the
James B Duke professor of psychology and
behavioral economics at Duke University
so I became interested in online dating
because one of the people who were
sitting in an office next to me was
incredibly miserable and he was an
assistant professor he just moved to the
University where I was at he was
spending long hours he was not finding
anybody to to date he was couldn't date
students at the University he was a
professor and he didn't have time to go
outside you know we were not
particularly social Bunch you know he
was he was basically stuck and online
dead it was a very promising way to
think about this solution for a
marketplace it wasn't working very well
and he tried online dating and he was
just failing miserably continuously so
that kind of piqued my curiosity about
it and then I started looking at online
dating so I started looking by
registering myself and looking at other
people and then I said let me ask some
of my friends to enroll so I didn't ask
them to really enroll I just took the
profile sheets and I asked people could
you fill those out but without your name
and I took people that I liked more and
I liked less and I took your profile I
tried to figure out could I tell the
difference you know and imagine you did
this imagine you went to 50 people you
really like in 50 people you only like
so-so and you ask all of them to fill
this profile then you took these hundred
profiles and you try to sort them out in
two piles terms that were terrible at
this right so this is kind of an initial
observation is that something is going
wrong in this in this market and then
went a step further did some studies
with online daters about how much they
enjoyed it and what they were getting
from it until the final stage we I
figure out I thought I knew what was
going on which is that online dating
site assume that people are easy to
describe on searchable attributes they
think that we're like digital cameras
that you can describe somebody by their
height and weight and political
affiliation and so on but it turns out
people are much more like wine that when
you taste the wine you could describe it
but it's not a very useful description
but you know if you like it or don't
it's the complexity and the completeness
of the experience it tells you if you
like a person or not and this is
breaking into attributes turns out not
to be very informative so in the last
stage of this process we created a
different website and that different
website allow people to experience other
people without all of these attributes
and we show that this is a
really much better and would lead to
much more much high probability of going
on a second on the real date afterwards
so so it kind of goes from an
observation to a little study to a bit
more details and finally proposing some
kind of solution of something that I
think would actually work better so the
site basically looks at real days and
think about what real dates are they are
not about sitting in the room and
interviewing each other about question
they're often about experiencing
something together in the real world and
I think it's because if you and I went
out and we went somewhere I would look
at how you react to the outside world
what music you like what you don't like
what kind of pictures you like what kind
of images how do you react to other
people what do you do in the restaurant
and through all these kind of non
explicit aspects I will learn something
about you and I would feel that I'm
learning something about you and the
online system we created was very much
like that it was about you came up when
you got a little avatar a square or
triangle some color and you want into a
virtual space in which you could explore
it and you could see lots of stuff there
were pictures and images and there were
words and there were movies and there
were bands there's all kinds of stuff
and you could go and when you came to
another little avatar you could start
chatting and you would chat about
something
it wasn't about interviewing when you
went to school and what's your religion
it was about talking about something
else and it turns out it gave people
much more information about each other
and they were much more likely to want
to meet each other for a first date and
for for a second date
so so I think that online dating is an
incredibly unsatisfying experience in
fact when we do surveys to understand
what people do they the basic trade-off
is for each six hours of searching for
people and emailing them you get one cup
of coffee and it's not as if people
enjoy online dating it's not as if they
have fun searching people in writing
blurbs for them
I mean imagine that you basically to
drive six hours three hours each way to
have coffee with somebody and you know
coffee usually ends up with just coffee
it's an incredibly unsatisfying
experience so I I think it's a really
bad it's a really bad system on top of
that there's another thing is which
imagine I gave you these search criteria
which asked you to search by height and
weight and income and all of those
things you're going to use it that's
what I give you to search you're going
to use it there's a million people out
there you want to limit them to 3,000
that's what we're going to that's what
you're going to use and because of that
I think actually people become much more
superficial than we think they are so
here's an example it turns out women
really care about men's height I'm five
nine if I want it to be as attractive as
somebody who is 510 right another inch I
would have to make about thirty five
forty thousand dollars more a year
that's a lot of money for one inch and
at the same time it turns out that men
care a lot about women's BMI in fact
they want women to be slightly on the
wreck circuit like eighteen and a half
and you look at women's attractiveness
it goes really up it low BMI and really
drops below that now people online look
incredibly superficial they look at hair
color and they look at height and they
look at income and that's basically it
an attractiveness of course and you can
ask it because that's all people care
about or is that because that's what the
system is giving them to search for and
I think it's because of combination
right sure we are so professional we do
care about attractiveness and in height
and income and these are these are
features for us but I think they're
exaggerated by the way the system is
created
imagine you were looking for something
else imagine you were looking for
digital cameras and imagine that I only
allow you to search on megapixels and
the f-stop for the lens right these
things will become incredibly
right and if I drop some things from the
search they will become as if they're
not important or much less important so
I think part of the problem is that the
systems don't give us the right
information that we that we need and
because of this I think the experience
of online dating is generally
unsatisfying I mean think about it how
many millions of people are
participating in this activity and
marriage rate has not increased divorce
rate has not decreased I mean not really
much has happened because of that and at
the same time I think it's incredibly
important right we the dating market is
is perhaps the only market that we moved
from a centralized market to a
decentralized market you know we used to
have a Yenta your parents used to tell
you what to do all this is gone now you
have to fend for yourself on top of that
we move a lot right you you go to one
place for undergrad then you go to grad
school then you move to another city for
a job do you study you move again you
have no time to create a social network
we work long hours so it's really a
system where we don't have time to find
people for ourselves it's very it's
taboo to date people at the workplace
the social networks are weaker in the
physical world we move all the time and
we don't have a yen tell parents to tell
us what to do so so online dating are
incredibly important it could be central
and crucial and we need to create them
because it's really a miserable
situation for most single people at the
same time the one that we have created
and they all look the same basically
there are no real differences between
them the ones that we're creating are
just not that useful
summative mating is the idea that if you
took all men and you rank them on how
attractive they are from the most
attractive to the least attractive when
you write it all women from the most
attractive to the least attractive and
you can think about attractiveness is
built being built from lots of stuff
right it's not just beauty
it could be beauty and intelligence and
so on but if you created this it was
mostly about beauty but you know if you
created that it turns out that the most
attractive would date the most
attractive the middle attractive would
basically date the middle and the low
would date you low now there could be
slight deviations but that's what
happened and why because if you're at
the top and you're a guy you can pick
anybody you want so you would pick a
woman who's in the top and if she's at
the top she could pick anybody she wants
you would pick you so now the question
is what happens with people in the
middle you know most of us what what
happens to people in the middle how do
we make sense of where we are in the
social hierarchy and and for me that
thought actually became very kind of
crucial and apparent when I got injured
so here's what happened you you grow up
and you have some kind of space in
society and you know basically where you
are and you know who would date you and
who would not date you who is kind of
outside of your league in general terms
and you know where you fit in the social
hierarchy and and I knew where I wasn't
a social hierarchy but one day I got
badly injured and you know I couldn't
think about romantic stuff for a long
time but when I could office and I
started wondering about where do I fall
now in the social hierarchy now trying
to think about do I fall in the same
place I'm kind of the same person inside
but I look much less attractive I think
with the women who would date me before
would keep on dating me now and I said
why would they they have other options
right I'm not the only guy in the world
okay so so it was kind of a very
difficult concept for me to think about
where do I fall like I felt differently
on the social hierarchy I basically lost
my space all of the time and I was
trying to understand how these social
dance happen and how we find our place
and I was really wondering about where
would I find my own mate where would I
fit in this in this scale and there's a
lot of kind of a personal complexities
with it but eventually it led me to a
study and the study was really asking
the question of how do we make sense of
what we fit in there in the hierarchy
and they're basically kind of multiple
explanations right you could say you
never adjust you never if you kind of in
the middle range or the low range and
you only are you have to date somebody
else who's in the middle range you never
make peace with it you wake up every
morning you look at your partner across
your shoulder and you say well that's
the best I could I really wanted more
sadly you know I have to admit my
limitations that's the most I could do
that means you don't adapt it could be
that you adapt it could be that for
example if you're unattractive you start
looking at other features that are
unattractive and Sydenham is attractive
you remember the story from Cree love
when you have this this wolf Sydney say
grapes over the fence and he tries to
get them and he can't get them and
eventually said ah there was sour anyway
and he goes and eats something else
right so you could imagine that if
you're unattractive yourself you start
valuing if you're a woman you start
valuing short men who are bald with bad
teeth right I mean you just say these
are really wonderful features I like
hairy chest I like ball head I mean you
basically change what you like and that
actually helps you adjust or you can
imagine it you start liking other things
you stop paying attention to
attractiveness and start paying
attention to other things so we tried
that in an experiment initially we went
to this website called hot or not it's a
wonderful website you see pictures of
people and you decide you rank them on a
scale from zero to ten about how
attractive they are and then you see how
you rated this person how other people
rated them but a nice feature about this
website is that if I rate people the
website knows how I was rated as well
because I have my picture there as well
by the way I'm not rated very high I
think I'm like 6.4 but they're people
who are rating you know how they're
rating and you know how they're rated so
now the question is the people who are
providing the rating they're people who
are really attractive that are providing
rating and people who are really
unattractive providing the rating and
the first thing you can ask is do they
have different ratings are the people
who are inherently unattractive do they
see beauty differently and the answer is
no we all see beauty in the same way the
people who are
9r eight people the same way as the
people who are for in the hotness rating
so so people don't change their sense of
beauty now you could say so maybe they
don't adjust at all maybe they don't
adapt that the people who are four keep
on looking for the people who are with
nine and or maybe they adapt some other
way so hot or not has another feature
which is the decide called meet me in
which you see pictures of people and you
side do I want to meet them or not now
it's not just reading it's about also
thinking about the probability that you
will be accepted or turn down and it's
not so an embarrassing to be turned
online but it's still a little bit
embarrassing so the question is the
people who are nine will they approach
different people than the people who are
four and the answer is absolutely yes
the people who are four basically
approach people who are four or five the
people who are nine approach people who
are nine or ten people are a little
optimistic they approach a little too
high but they basically know the range
so what happened is people know the
range they know where they are in the
social hierarchy but the same time they
see Beauty at the same thing so what
happens so how people solve it do they
wake up every morning feeling bad or do
they solve it in some way so the last
step we did a speed-dating event we got
people to do a speed-dating event and we
asked them to rate other people are lots
of attributes not just attractiveness
but all kinds of other things and what
we saw was the people who were very
attractive
cared more about attractiveness this is
like one of the dominating criteria they
want to date somebody who is attractive
well the people who are unattractive
basically say we don't care so much
about attractiveness we want people who
are kind and have a good sense of humor
so what happened is that the way people
adapt the people at the low end of the
scale is by changing their priorities
and office and saying I want people with
different set of attributes I don't care
so much about beauty I want somebody
who's kind good-hearted with a good
sense of humor and that's actually the
story for the petition so that's the
story of how we are coming into a social
hierarchy in a certain place and based
on our circumstances come to understand
differently what we want and don't want
and how we view the world in a way that
is compatible with where we are in the
social hierarchy
so I don't know if you've had the
experience of going to a Kia but I I go
from time to time and the last thing I
did was I built a toy chest for my for
my kids and when I got home with this
box actually set of boxes and I start
assembling them for me the instructions
were very unclear and I kept on screwing
things and screwing them wrongly and had
to disassemble and put it back together
and so on by the end of the day I I
worked a lot it was not a particularly
beautiful piece of furniture but I was
actually quite attached to it I think
that's kind of the interesting idea is
that when you put a lot of yourself into
it some sweat and energy and anger never
even frustration you end up loving the
end product a bit more so we try to do
this with experiments and we got people
to build their Legos and origamis and
all kinds of things and the first thing
we found was that if there was an
origami that you build in origami that
somebody else built you think that yours
is much much more beautiful not only is
it more beautiful you're willing to pay
much more for it right now the question
is why you can imagine I build in
origami that is uniquely good for me and
you the other origami is not so it's
unique to me it's not about the fact
that I kind of wrongly evaluated you
just let me have some features that I
particularly like so we asked people to
predict how other people would pay for
it and it turns out people are really
wrong with it not only do we like more
the origami we make we think other
people would love them as well and you
can think about kids like this right I
have two wonderful kids I love them
dearly I think they're amazing when we
go to a party and they dance or do
something I can't believe that any of
the parents would want to do anything
but look at my kids right and that's the
issue right there my kids I think they
are wonderful but not only that I think
that other people should see them as
wonderful as I see them and the same
thing happening with origami or with
everything we make not only do we over
value it we think that everybody will
share our our perspective and and this
of course creates both opportunities for
better things and opportunities for
mistakes right so if you're if you're a
company and you can create things that
people would actually put something of
themselves into it and actually value it
more
that's a great thing to do right there's
lots of opportunities for tailoring and
custom-made and user design on on the
web it's also about cooking for yourself
and doing your own garden and fixing
things yourself because we might not
understand it if we do something
ourselves we would like it more but the
fact is we we likely would do the same
thing but of course there's the downside
and the downside is if we create
something we end up loving it perhaps
too much we don't see it an objective
way and as a consequence we can make
mistakes as well that's actually a
general comment about rationality and
irrationality rationality or
irrationality is not always bad it's not
always that the irrational person is
better than irrational it's a mixture
right it's really wonderful that we can
love our kids so much that's that's why
we think they actually get to live and
we we care about them but at the same
time our blindness to them to them or to
the weaknesses can actually create some
negative consequences as well
so I think the world would actually be
quite terrible if everybody would be
would be perfectly rational and you know
when you ask people this question
initially they say oh yes I want
everybody to be rational but the fact is
that I pick the title the upside of
irrationality because I think there's a
lot of wonderful things about
irrationality I'll give you two examples
the first one is imagine that you left
your wallet on your desk and you went
out for lunch what are the odds that
somebody will steal it right and now
think about what are the odds that
somebody would steal it if everybody you
worked with was perfectly rational if
everybody was continuing the
cost-benefit analysis if that's all what
people were doing they would pass by
your desk they would say hey nobody is
here nobody is looking I can steal this
and have no chance of being caught let
me do that right in fact if we lived in
a society where everybody was just
maximizing their own self-interest all
the time it would be quite a terrible
place to live here's another example
imagine a game we call the trust game
and then I'll tell you about the trust
game with revenge so imagine two players
player a and player B and the trust game
looks like this we tell player a hey
player you have $20 you could do two
things you can either go home or you can
give your money to player B and you
don't know who player B is and you'll
never meet them if you send your money
to player B player B will get $80 the
money would quadruple magically on their
way and now play a big we decide to do
two things they could go home with $80
in which case you will get nothing or
they could send you back half the money
now think about this situation imagine
your player a and you ask yourself what
would player B do if player B was
perfectly rational what would they do
they will go home with all the money
right they will maximize the
self-interest why would they give you
back any money so if you thought that
player B was perfectly rational would
you send them the money of course not
right so the rational prediction is that
player B will never send the money back
and because of that player a will never
trust him to start with turns out people
are much nicer than economic theory
predicts there's a good chance that
player a will send them money and a good
chance of player B will send half the
money back and if you were player B you
can just imagine imagine you just got in
the mail somebody that says hey here's
what happened would you send the money
back or not right most people would do
it so people this is the case when
people are nice and economic
but imagine to your player a and you
send the money to player B and player B
took the money and left and now I come
to and I say really sorry player a you
lost all your money but I tell you what
if you go into your checking account and
you get more money out and you give it
to me for every dollar you give me I
will go I will hunt player B down and
I'll take two dollars away from them you
give me two dollars a hundred nine take
four you give me ten I'll hunt them down
and take 20 from them and the question
is would you lose more of your own money
to exert revenge on them you just lost
twenty dollars and you can lose even
more to exert revenge on them and
everybody who had a divorce or a big
breakup know the answer right when we
are feel betrayed we would spend lots
and lots of money to inflict even more
pain on the other side and when earns
fair and some of his friends did work
like this they basically put people in
imaging so they could image people's
brains while they were executing and
plotting revenge and what they saw was
that the activity of revenge was
rewarding it was pleasurable now again
it's irrational why would it be
rewarding and pleasurable think about it
this way imagine that you and I were
living on a desert island and imagine I
had the mango and you wanted my mango
and imagine I kind of looked I was away
for a minute and you could steal my
mango if you thought that the only thing
I was doing is a cost-benefit analysis
you would say hey if I steal Dan's mango
and run far away enough he will do the
cost-benefit analysis he will decide not
to chase me not to find out what
happened he'll just go and get a new
mango and under those circumstances a
good chance you'll take my mango away
but what if I was a revengeful type what
if you knew that if you stole my mango I
will not sleep and I will not rest I
will hunt you down it doesn't matter how
long it will take me and how far I have
to run and how many nights I will not
sleep I will hunt you down I'll take my
mango and all your bananas and your goat
and your whatever whatever it is under
that condition you will probably not
start with me to start with right you
will not take anything with me so the
way to understand it is that trusting is
irrational but we do it revenge
is irrational but we do it and we do it
because trust and revenge are actually
two sides of the same coin
Trust is incredibly important for
society imagine how we would live in a
society without trust but to have trust
we also have to have revenge and those
things together make sense
they are both irrational but they're
both make sense and they actually help
us to live in the better society so
would I prefer a society when everybody
is rational I don't think so not in
there not in a long shot
things that I think companies do to a
large degree that makes very little
sense is the use of focus groups so
think about what the strange idea is
that we take ten people who know
basically nothing about your project and
you put them in the room and you let
them talk for a while and then you take
their whatever they came up with is a
consequence of these two hours of random
thinking and you based your strategy on
it to a large degree and I I don't want
to say that focus groups are always
useless and also uninformative but I
think that taking this data and then
relying it as extensively as companies
do I think I think it's crazy in many
ways and the reason I think companies do
it is because when these people create a
sentence or an idea it's very easy to
say Joe focus group 17 said this and it
can help you create a formulate an idea
around it when if you said 87% of the
people said X he just doesn't have a
face it doesn't have a desire it's just
not as concrete and therefore people are
not as excited about the about the
notion so I think that focus group is
incredibly useful as a persuasive
attempt to tell people what to do but is
a way to find out information it's not
as useful as people think it is the
other thing that really puzzles me is
that companies how little they
understand about how incentives really
work so the biggest expenditure for
almost any company is salaries and you
ask people what do you know about the
relationship between salaries and
performance the answer is nothing right
and and the question is why don't they
study anything
why don't they study why don't they try
different performance different
incentive level and see how it influence
performance and they often say well the
law kind of law laws and if we have paid
some people one way in something another
way we might be sued and but in the last
two years with all these questions about
bonuses and so on I've gone to many
companies and said why don't we at least
do some surveys why don't we at least
see how happy people are on the months
when they give them you give them their
bonus and how productive they are and
the answer I got 100 percent of the time
is that people are really miserable in
ball
the season and because of that they
don't want to ask them any more
questions and I said if people are
miserable in bonus season shouldn't it
mean that you should study it understand
it and try to prevent it from next for
next year they said well well not this
year
this year was really miserable maybe
next year come back to us next year but
if you think about it's really
incredible now how do companies decide
about compensation they look at what
other companies are doing and try to
equate compensation to what other
companies are doing it but it's a place
of the blind leading the blind right and
then if we pay 5% more other people
would start doing it but the real
question is how do you pay and how do
you get people to care about their work
and become more productive and be
happier at their work and the answer is
not simply that more money is better
more money can be part of the equation
but it's also the question of how do you
give that money you give it a bonus you
give it as a fixed salary and you give
it as part of the benefits maybe you
give benefits for the gym do you send
people on vacation to the Bahamas and it
turns out that there are ways to use
money that is economically less
efficient but actually get people to be
more motivated care more and actually
become more productive
so this is you can think of as the baby
Jessica right when baby Jessica fell to
the well and she really suffered and her
parents must have been incredibly
miserable she got more CNN coverage in
Rwanda in Darfur right and the question
is why why does this happen and and why
do people care so much and it turns out
is the research on what's called the
identifiable victim effect and the
question is if you have how many lives
are at stake and how much do we care you
would expect that as more lives are at
stake we would care more maybe in a
linear relationship or maybe we would
care more in the beginning and they'll
be kind of a diminishing return like we
wouldn't care if it's a hundred or a
thousand but we care a lot at the bottom
range but it turns out the function is
different we care a lot about individual
life and you care less and less is the
pie is the number of people become
bigger and this goes to kind of an
observation is both Stalin and Mother
Teresa said Stalin said one death is a
tragedy a million death is a statistic
and mother Teresa said in the same
spirit if I look at the masses I will
never act if I look at the one I will
and both of them basically portray this
idea that what happened when we kind of
think about recruiting ourselves to act
against something it's not about our
mind thinking it's not about the cold
calculated thought about what's
worthwhile and what's the cost-benefit
analysis it's about our heart it's about
our emotions and the question is what
can activate emotion and it turns out
that an individual case can get us to
care versus a big set of cases just
become statistics so this beautiful
results by a Deb small and George
Lowenstein and Paul slovic that
basically say here is one girl in Africa
who is hungry how much money would you
give her and then two other people they
say here's the problem of hunger in
Africa there are three million kids in
Sudan and there are five million kids
here and this how much money would you
give and people give half as much to
Africa then they give to the single girl
rukia it actually gets worse because you
said if people give more when it's
emotional than when it's statistical
what happens when we give both
information well say hey here's one girl
Rokia think you see
how sad she is and how much money could
help her by the way there's five million
more like her what would happen it goes
down it turns out that every time you
activate cognition calculation
thoughtfulness you turn off the emotion
people care less and give much less and
of course this explains a little bit
they kind of imbalance between what we
give to and what we don't give to so
think about how difficult it is to get
money for prevention of diseases
prevention of malaria or prevention of
diarrhea or deworming kids in the world
you know lots of kids have have worms it
turns out that those things are
incredibly important incredibly useful
you can actually get people to be much
much healthier but it's not motivating
right deworming a kids or you know
million kids in India just doesn't make
you feel woman
on fuzzy or preventing kids in the
future from getting malaria is again not
that exciting but if you can help one
person specific concrete get something
we all get very excited from it so there
is a real imbalance between what really
matters and what we care about and what
we gave our time and money to
if you run enough for profit of course
you want to build on these on this
irrationalities because you care about
your not-for-profit and i think the
example here is of course the American
Cancer Society they've done a really
good job first of all the word cancer is
great in in a money recruiting way right
it's an it's an awful disease the second
thing is the word survivor is really
good and the first thing they do is they
create an incredible fear from cancer I
mean the truth is we all have lots of
cancer and we all usually get get over
it I mean some some people of course
don't but in our lifetime will all have
cancerous cells and in most cases it
will be just part of the deal of living
and but but they create is these really
negative association that now everybody
who had cancer even if it was not
malignant and will not cause them to die
or it was so slow it will take 50 years
to develop and they call everybody a
cancer survivor and because of that
everybody who knows them and everybody
who cares about them start caring about
about cancer now you know it's kind of
interesting because they've basically
have mastered this issue right they've
mastered making it central focal created
very strong fear about about cancer and
in caring about it and they basically
get a lot of money and if you look at
them as a non-for-profit they are an
incredibly wealthy not-for-profit in
fact they other not-for-profits feel
that the Cancer Society is getting so
much money that people just don't give
to other causes because they give so
much to that cause and now there's all
kinds of movements to basically stop
their statuses and on for profit because
they're so wealthy and they spend so
much money on salaries and and so on but
but in a sense of understanding human
psychology they're the top basically
lots of lot of behavior like this so the
basic essence is the trade-off between
the short term in the long term I'm
really kind of a personal story about
this when I was in hospital a long time
ago I got liver disease from bad blood
transfusion and for a long time and you
know what it was and from time to time I
would get some liver infection it was it
was kind of bad in about seven years
after I got injured I was already out in
hospital I was in grad school I had
another flare-up I checked myself into
hospital and they found out it was
hepatitis C and they there was an
experimental treatment at that time call
interferon said why don't you try why
don't you try this I was very happy to
try it because you know who would want
to die from liver cirrhosis and I
basically got these injections I had to
inject myself three times a week for a
year and a half and these injections
basically symbolize for me they kind of
the essence of the human condition here
was an injection that could potentially
be very useful for me thirty years later
but what happened is that he also had
very bad side effects so every time I
would take an injection it would be sick
for about 16 hours
vomiting shaking fever nothing really
terrible compared to liver cirrhosis but
for sure unpleasant and now and here's
the question
liver really important injections
slightly important but now in for
certain and that's basically a trade-off
we have everything it's about saving not
good for now
good for the future exercising not good
for now good for the future dieting not
good for now good for the future safe
sex
not so good for now good for the future
lots of things have this trade-off in
terms of when we face these trade-offs
we often do what's called the present
bias focus we focus on the present too
much and as a consequence we undermine
the the long term the long term effect
this is the problem of Adam and Eve you
could ask yourself you know who would
ever give internally in the Garden of
Eden for an apple well if you ever
texted and drive at the same time you
basically have done this mistake right
and most people have texted
while while driving and and why do we do
it it's not because we weigh the
cost-benefit analysis and we say it's a
really good idea
to text while driving it's because we're
tempted at the moment to do something
that we realize is really stupid
from the long-term perspective now back
to my my story when I after a year and a
half there were two piece of good news
there first one was that my liver was
working fine and there was no trace of
the disease and the second thing is that
doctors told me was that I was the only
patient they ever had who took the
medication on time
the question is how could I do it do I
have nerves of steel and might not
succumb to temptation the answer is of
course we also come to temptation all
the time there's no difference but what
I did was I found a trick and my trick
is that I love movies if I had time I
would watch lots and lots of movies so
every Monday Wednesday and Friday on the
way to school I would stop at the video
store I would rent two or three videos I
really wanted to see I would carry them
in my backpack the whole day
anticipating watching them I would get
home I would give myself the injection I
would push a video in I would get the
bucket that would get the blanket I was
already - the side effect and I will
start the video immediately I would to
wait for the side effect to settle in I
started immediately now you can ask
yourself did I really care about my
liver and the answer is no the fact is
that the liver is really important and
me and all the other patients should
have kept on taking her medication on
time because of the liver but it wasn't
strong enough so what did I do
I substituted the liver with movies now
you might say this is a stupid idea
liver is really important movies not
that crucial if you ask me what do I
prefer movies or liver you know there's
no question but we can't delivers in the
future it was vastly discounted because
the movies were in immediately it was
actually motivating me and we call this
reward substitution when I behaved as if
I care about my liver by actually caring
about movies and I think is actually a
big lesson there you can think about how
do we get people to care about their
health and money and longevity and so on
can we really get people to wake up
every day and care about those things
that will happen thirty years from now
the answer is it will be very difficult
expensive and
likely but can we find other rewards
substitution can we get people to behave
because of other things in a way that
would make them behave as if they care
about the things that they're doing for
so why do people go to the gym right
do they really wake up every morning
worrying about how they will look feel
like 30 years from now
probably not but can we get them to do
some of these about the moment that
actually get them to behave because they
do something that makes them care about
behaviors if they care about something
else and I think that reward
substitution actually provides a general
answer to lots of problems in in human
behavior we just need to find out what
these rewards can be
absolutely so if you think about the
question of trust and revenge that's a
great example right the fact is that we
live in a society we're inherently
social animals unlike some other species
and because of that we need things that
kind of connects us in a social way so
we have this social utility in which we
just care about other people now let's
created lots of problems for example if
you do a favor to me I like you more and
then it might put me in such in conflict
of interest because I would want to
reciprocate in some way or you know
trust and revenge and all of those
things so the fact is that there are
some things that we are irrational and
we would have liked to fix it but
there's something who are irrationality
is actually what allows us to live in a
society and if we lived as individual
organisms that basically had no social
ties and we're just working each one of
us separately it'll be a very different
social structure but we might want to
actually have different strategies for
decision making but because we're
inherently social animal there's all
kinds of things that make that are
irrational from the perspective of
thinking that everybody is a social
Daisy is a selfish Maximizer but
nevertheless makes sense when you think
about people as social animals the other
thing of course is about processing
information so the fact is that we have
a limited brain you know we're kind of
limited physically in many ways right we
can't jump very high
we can't sustain cold or heat I mean
think about all the stuff in the world
that we do to make yourself more
comfortable we have chairs and clothes
and glasses and headphones I mean lots
and lots of stuff it turns out our brain
is also not perfect right in the same
way that our bodies are not perfect that
we can't do everything we would like to
we're not Superman our brain is also not
perfect our brain process information in
a certain way and the reality that we
experience is not out there it's in here
that's what gives us that the brain
gives us the world it brought to us
courtesy of our brain and it's
processing ability and and because the
brain is not perfect the way we get
information and process is also not
perfect and they're just kind of
functional structural limitations to how
rational we can be and the
fact is that we better recognize it it's
really good to recognize it understand
the limitation then act accordingly come
if we don't you know we'll just make
more and more mistake we'll just assume
that we can be perfect we'll create the
world as if people would create it can
be perfect and we'll just set ourselves
to this appointment time after time